[संगीत]
यह ए गया
हेलो एवरीवन वेरी गुड इवनिंग तो जो
वेलकम तू डेट
करने वाले हैं जो हमने स्टार्ट किया था
कुछ दिन 12 दिन पहले
जो अल्टर डेज पर आपका चल रहा था तो दो
क्लासेस और बच्ची हुई है उसके बाद हम क्या
कर देंगे
[संगीत]
और कर देंगे
काफी इंजॉय किया होगा और दें प्रोसीड पर
डी तू अंदर टॉपिक अनाउंसमेंट
तो एक बार मुझे आप लोग बता दीजिए की आप
लोग सबको मेरी आवाज सही से सुने दे रही है
नहीं सुने दे दी एक बार बता दीजिए ताकि
मुझे पता चल सके की
आप लोगों से इसे सुने दे रहा नहीं दे रहा
है
हमारे साथ
ओके थैंक यू
अभी तक जो हमने पढ़ा है
जो भी हमें पटाया है किसी का कोई डाउट है
तो अभी तक आप लोगों ने कोई डाउट हमसे पूछा
नहीं है तो इसका मतलब मैं समझ सकता हूं की
आप लोगों को सही से सब कुछ समझ में ए रहा
है और आप लोगों का कॉन्सेप्ट क्लियर
तो आज जो हम टॉपिक पढ़ने वाले हैं आप
इंटरेस्टिंग टॉपिक है काफी अच्छा टॉपिक है
बेसिक टॉपिक है यह भी बेसिक आता है
आपको इसकी नॉलेज हनी चाहिए किसी को पहले
से नॉलेज होगी और किसी को नहीं होगी
क्या कर सकते हैं
तो उसके बड़े में डिस्कस करने वाले हैं
जो आपके लिए बहुत ज्यादा इंपॉर्टेंट है
उनके बड़े में डिस्कस करेंगे
[संगीत]
इंक्रीज कर देता हूं
व्हाट इसे
पैरामीटर पैरामीटर क्या है
पोजीशन
क्या होता है
रोज वैल्यू रोज वैल्यू यू कैन
मैन्युअल चेंज
मतलब क्या है
जिसके अंदर हम क्या करते हैं
अगर आपको इससे पहले वेरिएबल के बड़े में
नहीं सुना होगा अगर कोई भी नॉलेज नहीं
आपको वैरियेबल्स के बड़े में डोंट वारी
आपको जरूर नहीं है उसको बताने वाला हूं
देखो हम सोच सकते हैं की हमारे
प्रोग्राम्स में छोटे-छोटे बॉक्स हैं हम
क्या सोच सकते हैं की जब भी हम अपना
प्रोग्राम
डेट मेंस
डेट मेंस यू आर पुटिंग
पुटिंग डाटा
इन थे बॉक्स अब क्या करो उसे बॉक्स
का एग्जांपल
क्या कर रहे हो डाटा को रख रहे हो जिसको
हमें वेरिएबल बोल रहे हैं
इसका मतलब क्या है इसका मतलब है
बैक आउट
मतलब क्या मैं समझा जाता हूं मैंने क्या
बोला था की जब भी आप अपनी
मशीन में या आप अपने कंप्यूटर में या कोई
डायलॉग
बॉक्स में क्या करता है डाटा रखना है और
उसे बॉक्स का एक नाम रख देता है और जब नाम
रख देता है तो जब उसे नाम को हम क्या बोल
रहे हैं वेरिएबल बोल रहे हैं ओके और उसके
अंदर जो वैल्यू पट कर रहे हैं
तो जब मैं क्या बोल रहा हूं जब हमने क्या
कर दिया की जब हमने एक जो वेरिएबल है उसे
बॉक्स के बॉक्स को क्या कर दिया जब हमने
एक वैल्यू और साइन कर दी उसके अंदर जब
हमें डाटा रख दिया इसका मतलब क्या है की
मैं आपको कंफ्यूज कर रहा हूं मैं क्लियर
बोल रहा हूं
उसका मतलब ये है की आप उसे बॉक्स के अंदर
शूट डाटा को रख रहे हो उसे बॉक्स के अंदर
उसे वैल्यू को दाल रहे हो यह है उसका मतलब
वेरिएबल का मतलब अगर आप किसी एक वेरिएबल
को रेफरेंस ले रहे हो रेफर कर रहे हो इसका
मतलब क्या है की उसे बॉक्स के अंदर जी
बॉक्स का नाम आपने एक नाम रखा हुआ है
जिसको वेरिएबल बोल रहे हैं उसके अंदर एक
वैल्यू है जब हम उसे बॉक्स में रेफर कर
रहे हैं मतलब तो मतलब ये है की मैं उसे
बॉक्स के अंदर से डाटा क्या कर रहा हूं
बैक आउट कर रहा हूं निकाल रहा हूं सिंपल
मतलब ये है बॉक्स के अंदर अगर मैं वैल्यू
रख रहा हूं तो मतलब जब वैल्यू क्या कर रहा
हूं असाइन कर रहा हूं इसका मतलब बॉक्स के
अंदर में वैल्यू रख रहा हूं उसे वेरिएबल
के अंदर क्या कर रहा हूं वैल्यू असाइन
करता हूं अगर जब मैं बॉक्स से जो डाटा है
हमने रखा है उसको मैं आउट कर रहा हूं या
वालुज बॉक्स के अंदर जो राखी है मैंने
उसको आउट कर रहा हूं तो सिंपली इसका मतलब
क्या मैं वेरिएबल को रेफर कर रहा हूं मतलब
पर एग्जांपल मैं एग्जांपल ले सकता हूं की
कई बार आप शॉप में मेडिकल शॉप में जाते
हैं तो क्या करते हैं बहुत सारे बॉक्स
क्या करते हैं अपने पास रखते हैं रेफरेंस
के लिए वो क्या करते हैं की जब भी कोई
मेडिसिन का नाम देखते हैं तो क्या
डायरेक्टली उसे बॉक्स में जाते हो उसे
डायरेक्शन में निकाल के देते हैं वो बॉक्स
क्या है जिसके अंदर मेडिसिन राखी हुई है
वो क्या वैल्यू है वो डाटा है और उसे
बॉक्स का कुछ ना कुछ एक नाम रखा हुआ है की
100 डेट की जब वो आईडेंटिफाई कर पे
डायरेक्टली तो ये एक छोटा सा
एग्जांपल्स होते हैं बात करते हैं
डर आर
तू
टाइप्स ऑफ वेरिएबल टाइप्स ऑफ वैरियेबल्स
स्पेलिंग
बोल सकते हैं
दूसरा जो होता है दूसरे कौन से होते हैं
क्रिएट किया जाते हैं
उनको बोलते हैं यूजर डिफाइंड वैरियेबल्स
सिंपली आपके मशीन में अगर आपको आईडेंटिफाई
करना है कौन-कौन से यूजर डिफाइंड
वैरियेबल्स है कौन से आपके सिस्टर डिमांड
वेरिएबल तो आईडेंटिफाई करने का इजी तरीका
है ये कोई कंपलसरी कंडीशन है लेकिन हम
जनरली क्या करते हैं अपनी मशीन के अंदर
नाम जनरली क्या करके रखते हैं जो हमारी
मशीन है उसमें जो सिस्टम डिफाइंड
वैरियेबल्स है ये जो एनवायरनमेंट
वैरियेबल्स उनको कैपिटल में रखते हैं
ऐसी कोई कंडीशन नहीं है की आपको कैपिटल
में ही रखना है सिस्टम डिमांड वैरियेबल्स
वेरिएबल को स्मॉल में क्रिएट करना नहीं हम
ताकि आईडेंटिफाई कर पे की कौन सा सिस्टम
डिफाइन वैरियेबल्स है वो
चीज आईडेंटिफाई करने के लिए हम क्या करते
हैं
लेकिन देवर इसे नो कंडीशन नो पॉलिसी की
आपको सिस्टम डिफाइंड वैरियेबल्स को कैपिटल
में ही रखना है नहीं लेकिन
लेट टॉक अबाउट
नाम वेरिएबल नाम उसके बाद इक्वल साइन उसके
बाद उसके अंदर क्या रखते हैं वैल्यू ये एक
सिंटेक्स है किसी भी वेरिएबल को डिफाइन
करने के लिए यहां पर हमें एक चीज ध्यान
में रखती है की जब भी हम कोई भी वैरायटी
करते हैं या किसी भी वेरिएबल कंपेयर करते
हैं तो हमें इक्वल साइन के बीच में स्पेस
उसे नहीं करना है मतलब यहां पर इक्वल साइन
से पहले और इक्वल सेल के साइन के बाद मुझे
स्पेस उसे नहीं करना है मुझे ऐसे ही
डिफाइन करना है बेस्ट के कैसे में वेरिएबल
को डिफाइन करते वक्त ये चीज आपको ध्यान
में रखती है पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या रखा
मैंने वेरिएबल का नाम रखा
है उसका नाम मैंने प्रैक्टिस वेरिएबल का
नाम रखा
उसके अंदर वैल्यू रखना हूं जैसे की कोई भी
नाम रख लेट हूं
इकोनामिक
वेरिएबल है
अगर आपको क्या करना है रेफरेंस करना है
इसके अंदर के डाटा को खींच करना है अगर
आपको क्या करना है की यह देखना है की इस
वेरिएबल के अंदर क्या वैल्यू है तो उसका
भी एक सिंटेक्स होता है जैसे हम करेंगे को
को उसके बाद क्या करोगे आपको एक जो ऑफिशल
सिंटेक्स है वो बताओ
इसका नाम देते हो उसे वेरिएबल का नाम
टैक्स है जो जनरली आपको फॉलो करना चाहिए
अदर वाइस ये सही तरीका
लेकिन एक वो अच्छा तरीका है
वो कर सकते हो तो क्या होता है की
जो प्रैक्टिस के अंदर जो वैल्यू है ना
इसको क्या करता है इसके साथ क्या कर देता
है रिप्लेस कर देता है तो यहां पर अप को
सचिन ए जाएगा और आपका आउटपुट आपके स्क्रीन
पर देखने को मिलता है कमांड का बेसिकली कम
क्या है ये आउटपुट को आपके स्क्रीन पे शो
करना है अब ये सब करने का फायदा क्या है
देखो हम सिंपली ये भी कर सकते थे ना की इस
वैल्यू को डायरेक्ट अपनी कमांड्स में रख
दें और उसे कर लेने इससे इजी कुछ नहीं हो
सकता ना तो इसका में बेनिफिट तो हमें तब
देखने को मिलता है जब हम कोई भी स्क्रिप्ट
बना रहे होते हैं या बना चुके होते हैं
अब स्किप क्या होती है
हो सकता है
वेरिएबल डिफाइन कर रखा होगा मैं सिंपली
क्या करूंगा इस वेरिएबल की वैल्यू में
क्या कर दूंगा उसे वैल्यू को चेंज कर
दूंगा और जो 50 की 50 जगह है एवं 50 की
जगह 1000 टाइम्स 20 वेरिएबल को उसे किया
हुआ है तो वो ऑटोमेटेकली एक बार में ही
चेंज हो जाएगा आपको 50 टाइम्स उसको चेंज
करने की जरूर नहीं पड़ेगी या कंट्रोल एफ
करके या फाइंड और रिप्लेस नहीं करना
पड़ेगा इतनी मेहनत नहीं करनी पड़ेगी
ऐसी सिचुएशंस को निपटाने के लिए हमने
वैरियेबल्स का उसे करते हैं तो आपको समझ
में ए गया होगा अब जैसे पर एग्जांपल दिखता
हूं आपको एग्जांपल वेरिएबल कैसे मैंने
प्रेक्टिस पी आर ए सी
प्रैक्टिस
बताया जाए
यह वेरिएबल अभी टेंपरेरी है यह वैरियेबल्स
क्या है अभी तक क्या है
परमानेंट करने के लिए आपको क्या करना
पड़ेगा अगर इस वेरिएबल को आप अपने मशीन
में परमानेंट डिफाइन करना है तो आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा इसकी प्रोफाइल फाइल में इसकी
एंट्री करनी पड़ेगी प्रोफाइल फाइल्स की
एंट्री करनी पड़ेगी और एक चीज बताता हूं
आपको जब भी किसी वेरिएबल को आप डिफाइन
करते हैं तो किसी भी वेरिएबल डिफाइन करते
हुए एक चीज ध्यान में रखना है की वो
वेरिएबल डायरेक्टली किसी भी स्पेशल
करैक्टर या किसी भी नंबर से स्टार्ट नहीं
होगा वो हमेशा की स्मॉल या कैपिटल
अल्फाबेट से ही स्टार्ट होगा कोई भी
वेरिएबल डायरेक्टली नंबर से स्टार्ट नहीं
होगा अगर आपको देखना है पर एग्जांपल मैं
देखना चाहता हूं तू उसके बाद प्रैक्टिस पी
आर ए सी टी आई सी प्रेक्टिस इक्वल दिया
मैंने एस एस सी हा आई एन ये क्या बोल रहा
है
तो वेरिएबल को डिफाइन करते हो तो आपको
हमेशा ध्यान रखना है वो अल्फाबेट से
स्टार्ट होगा
अब बात करते हम सिस्टम डिमांड वेरिएबल
सिस्टम
सिस्टम डिफाइन वैरियेबल्स
को हम क्या बोलते हैं एनवायरनमेंट
वैरियेबल्स भी बोल सकते हैं यस सिस्टम
डिफाइन वैरियेबल्स के अंदर जो भी
वैरियेबल्स आते हैं जिनको हम कैपिटल लेटर
में देखने को मिलेंगे
इसके अंदर आते हैं आपके
एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स के अंदर ही आते
हैं देखो पर एग्जांपल एक एग्जांपल लेट हूं
जब आप कहानी भी किसी भी कंपनी में कम करने
के लिए जाते हैं पर एग्जांपल किसी भी
कंपनी में चाहे आप एक अकाउंटेंट सिस्टम
एनवायरनमेंट सेट करके दिया जाता है
तो उसको पहले से ही एक एनवायरनमेंट मिलता
है कम करने के लिए उसके उसके बाद वो क्या
करता है उसके अकॉर्डिंग क्या करता है वो
चेंज जरूर कर सकता है लेकिन पहले से ही जब
आप क्या करते हो अपनी मशीन में यूजर मिल
लॉगिन करते हो तो आपको क्या करता हूं आप
पहले से ही उसे लेटर बहुत साड़ी फाइल्स
आपको देखने को मिलती है डायरेक्टर्स आपको
देखने को मिलती है हो सकता है वहां पर कुछ
पॉलिसीज आपको देखने को मिले तो ये सब
किसके कान पॉसिबल है जी एन पॉसिबल हो
एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स तो ऐसे आप कंपेयर
कर सकते हो एक अपने रियल लाइफ के साथ अब
बात करते हैं कुछ आम एनवायरनमेंट
वैरियेबल्स है जिनके बड़े में आपको जानना
बहुत ज्यादा जरूरी है और प्रैक्टिकल दिखता
हूं पर एग्जांपल सबसे पहले हम अप को मैं
करता हूं डॉलर
एस है आपका ये रूट मशीन है तो रूट का जो
होम डायरेक्टरी है उसका पाठ आपके स्क्रीन
के सामने एब्सलूट पाठ को क्या करता है ये
आपके स्क्रीन के सामने
प्रिंट करके दिखता है एक और वेरिएबल होता
है
उसका नाम आपके स्क्रीन पर प्रिंट आउट करके
दे देता है
और डॉलर
उसके बाद क्या है
पोस्ट नाम पोस्ट नाम यह आपके मशीन का हाउस
नाम रिप्रेजेंट करता है अभी क्या है हमारी
मशीन में कोई भी होस्ट नाम हा ओ एस टी
कोर्स नाम सेट नहीं किया है तो इसलिए क्या
है
पोस्ट को डॉलर
और नाम
यह भी हो सकता है की हमारी मशीन में हमने
होस्ट ने उसे टाइप को क्या किया हुआ अभी
तक सेट नहीं किया इसलिए इसका आउटपुट कोई
भी स्क्रीन पर शो नहीं कर रहा है लेकिन
क्या होता है
की व्हाट टाइप ऑफ प्रोसेस आर्किटेक्चर डी
कंप्यूटर
में कैट करके दिखाऊं प्लस ईटीसी के अंदर
एक ईटीसी के अंदर एक होता है
आर्किटेक्चर क्या है इसकी ओके वर्जन वर्जन
वर्जन वर्जन वर्जन यहां पर आर्किटेक्चर
आपको देखने को ही नहीं मिल रही है
सी ल ल सेल यदि प्रेजेंट करता है की ओके
चित करता हूं मैं एक सेल से उसके बाद में
क्या करता हूं
शुरू करता हूं
रिप्रेजेंट करता है आपको जस हो रहा है
आपकी इस मशीन के अंदर यह सेल की इनफॉरमेशन
आता है एक और एनवायरमेंटल एक और डॉलर
प्रेजेंट करता है डायरेक्टली उसका आउटपुट
कहां से आता है इसी एनवायरनमेंट वेरिएबल
से आता है अब बात करते हैं एक और
एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स होता है
यह जो कमांड है डायरेक्टली एग्जीक्यूट
कैसे हो जाति है
तो इस सिस्टम को कैसे पता चला की इसकी बेन
भी फाइल कहां पर लोकेटेड है
पर एग्जांपल
उसके लिए कमांड होती है
तो इसने बता दिया की लिक कर रखा है
तो डायरेक्टली ऑटोमेटेकली
उसके बड़े में पता कर लिया लेकिन सिस्टम
को कैसे पता चला
है
एवं पासवर्ड
है तो यह सब पॉसिबल है किसकी हेल्प से
इस्पात वैरियेबल्स की हेल्प से जो पास एक
एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स है इसकी हेल्प से
यह सपोजिबल है इसी वेरिएबल की हेल्प से
सिस्टम जानता है की सुपर यूजर की बिंदे
फाइल्स कहां पर लोकेटेड है सुपर यूजर्स की
बाइनरी फाइल कहां पर लोकेटेड
की लोकेशन कहां पर है
अगर फिर क्या होता है अगर आपको सुपर
यूजर्स जैसे सुपर यूजर्स के बड़े में फाइल
है ये भी नॉर्मल यूजर्स
यह नॉर्मली यूजर्स
अगर आपको क्या होता है की अगर आपकी जो
बाइनरी फाइल्स है जो आप कमांड फायर करते
हो अगर वो सुपर यूजर नॉर्मल नहीं मिलती
उसके बाद क्या करता जो बाकी बच्ची हुई
इसमें लेस्बियन लोकल गेम्स
इनके अंदर फाइंड आउट करने की कोशिश करता
है उसको मन को अगर इनके अंदर मिल जाति है
तो क्या करता है
फाइल पास नॉर्मल यूजर्स के उसमें है
ना नॉर्मल
लोकेशन पर है ना ही इसमें से जो जितने भी
पार्ट डिफाइंड किया है उसके अंदर वो
डिफाइंड नहीं है तो क्या होगा उसे कमांड
को एग्जिट करने के लिए आपको क्या करना
पड़ेगा
क्या करना पड़ेगा
उसका क्या करना पड़ेगा आपको फूल बाइनरी
पाठ आपको देना पड़ेगा पर एग्जांपल मुझे
अगर इसी कमांड पर एग्जीक्यूट करवाना है तो
मैं कैसे करूंगा अगर इसकी एंट्री
आपकी अगर इसकी एंट्री उसे फाइल के अंदर
नहीं है
तो क्या करना आपको फूल बैटरी का देना
पड़ेगा अब देखो
ही कर देता हूं क्योंकि मैं पासवर्ड सेट
नहीं करना चाहता
हूं
जिसका नाम है
यह करता हूं मैं आपको डॉलर
को मिलेगा
कुछ मतलब होता है
बहुत साड़ी जगह आपको देखने को मिला होगा
ए आर ओ एम पी टी फ्रॉम
लाइनेक्स टर्मिनल
जूम करता हूं
देखने को मिलेगा पर एग्जांपल पर एग्जांपल
मेरा
कंट्रोल सी
कंट्रोल
वेबसाइट
कैसे कर सकते हैं
और यहां पर रख लेते हम इसको कंट्रोल शिफ्ट
हमारे कम आएगा
और डॉलर
ओके फिर से मैं क्या शुरू करता हूं तो आप
इसे हो जाए
परमानेंट सेट करना चाहते हो अगर आप इस
वेरिएबल को परमानेंट सेट करना चाहते हैं
तो सिंपली क्या करोगे इसकी एंट्री यार
प्रोफाइल
कौन सी है मुझे बम करना है अभी सिंपली डॉट
बेस्ट एआरसी बेस्ट आरसी बस आपको नीचे
देखने को मिल रहा होगा बेस्ट आरसी इंटर
करूंगा और सबसे इसके और में क्या आया हूं
सबसे लास्ट में जाऊंगा और इसके एंट्री में
क्या कर दूंगा सबसे और में इसके एंट्री
में कर दो जैसे का था ना ऐसे इसके नीचे
मैं एंट्री इसकी बना दूंगा तो ये क्या हो
जाएगा परमानेंटली सेट हो जाएगा
तो यह आपको पता चल गया होगा की ps1
वैरियेबल्स इतना इंपॉर्टेंट क्यों है
क्योंकि कैसा भी चाहिए इसको आप मॉडिफाई कर
सकते हैं बहुत जगह आपको देखने को मिलता है
की यहां पर यहां पर रूट होम काली देखने को
मिलता है आप जैसा चाहे जैसा सेट कर सकते
हो ये आपकी काफी हेल्प करेगी ये वेबसाइट
है काफी हेल्प करेगी जी हिसाब से आप
आउटपुट चाहते हैं इस हिसाब से आउटपुट आपकी
स्क्रीन कैसे आएगा देखो ये रिव्यू भी करके
दिखा रहा है यूजर नाम आएगा ओके उसके बाद
ओके संडे जो लाइन है ऐसे आपको देख रहे हो
देखने को मिलेगा अगर कुछ एक्स्ट्रा
करैक्टर एड करना चाहते हो
@ करना चाहते हो उसके बाद आप क्या करते हो
बेसिकलमेंट में आप उसके बाद क्या है पार्ट
तू करंट डायरेक्टरी ओके ऐसे आपको देखने को
मिलेगा उसके बाद आप डॉलर साइन भी साथ है
ऐसे तो ये आपको ऐसे देखने को मिलेगा
ऐसे आपका स्क्रीन पर आउटपुट देखने को
मिलेगा
सिंपली एक्सपोर्ट कर डॉग तो परमानेंटली हो
जाएगा एक्सपोर्ट ps1 वैरियेबल्स ये हो
जाएगा डायरेक्टली ये कम करेगा
इनफॉरमेशन
जो करवाया आप लोगों का क्लियर हुआ
प्लीज एक बार बता दीजिए
बताइए बता दीजिए की आप लोगों को अभी तक
मैंने जितना करवाया अभी जब स्टार्टिंग से
अभी तक क्या सबको क्लियर हुआ या कोई डाउट
है इसमें
ps1 वेरिएबल सिस्टम डिफाइन
वैरियेबल्स में डाउट और नोट बता दीजिए एक
बार
लगता है
दिस इसे डी लाइनेक्स कैप्सूल कोर्स नोट डी
पेन टेस्टिंग कोर्स आईएफ दिस बिल बी डी
पेन टेस्टिंग कोर्स डेन वे बिल तेज अबाउट
की हो तू न्यूमैरेटर यूजर्स नेम्स और
पासवर्ड हो तू बी
ट्री तू क्रैक आईटी आईएफ पॉसिबल अगर आपका
पासवर्ड स्ट्रांग होगा
क्रिप्टोग्राफी
स्किल कैसी है आप किस हद तक
इनफॉरमेशन गैदरिंग कर पाते हैं किसी भी
टारगेट के बड़े में
से पासवर्ड क्रैक करना हमने सिखाएंगे बट
वन थिंक आई बिल टीच यू की अगर आप आपके
मशीन ऑन करो आप रूट का पासवर्ड भूल गए तो
उसको आप कैसे चेंज क्या कर सकते हो चेंज
कर सकते हो वो मैं आपको शिखा दूंगा डोंट
वारी आते डी और ऑफ डी दिस कोर्स
की अभी हमने क्या किया जितने भी
एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स हैं
या हमने सेट किया है अगर उनको हम कैसे देख
सकते हैं
अगर आप क्या कर सकते हो किसी वेरिएबल को
सेट और अनसेट कर सकते हो लेकिन टेंपरेरी
अगर आपको क्या टेंपरेरी किसी वैरियेबल्स
को क्या करना है अनसेट करना है तो कैसे कर
सकते हैं वह भी कर सकते हैं और वो कैसे कर
सकते हो वो मैं आपको बताऊंगा लेकिन
[संगीत]
चाट और सिंपली अनसेट करने के लिए क्या
करोगे आप सिंपली क्या कर सकते हो सेट और
मैं आपको एक्सटेंशन बता देता हूं इसका सेट
सेट और वेरिएबल का नाम
यह सेट हो जाएगा
तो आप सेट कर सकते हो मतलब
आपको सीखना हूं एक चीज बहुत ही
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज दिखता हूं की हो तू
एक्सपोर्ट वैरियेबल्स
वैरियेबल्स पर एग्जांपल
वार वन और एक टेस्ट एक वार 18
की वैल्यू
एस हा ए ल ल देखा हूं ओके
800 कैश की वैल्यू आपकी स्क्रीन पे आई
नहीं आई क्योंकि सेल चेंज हो गया
एक्सेस करना है किसी भी दूसरे सेल से तो
आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा एक्सपोर्ट करना
पड़ेगा क्या करना पड़ेगा
मैं सिंपली कैसे एक्सपोर्ट कर सकता हूं
किसी भी वेरिएबल लेकिन ये कम कर टेंपरेचर
कुछ वेरिएबल का नाम एक्सपोर्ट क्या करता
हूं मैं वेरिएबल का नाम डॉलर
हुआ है
अब मैंने क्या किया
करता हूं और डॉलर
को बता चुका हूं
एग्जिट करता हूं
अगर
एस हा ल बी ल के सेंटर
क्या का सकते हो आप टेंपरेरी किसी भी
वैरियेबल्स को क्या कर सकते हो एक्सपोर्ट
कर सकते हो या सेट कर सकते हो ऐसे कर सकते
हैं
वन इक्वल तू कार्बन
इसको मार वन उसके बाद एस्केप मोड उसके बाद
कमांड
क्योंकि ये इसकी बेस्ट आरसी फाइल इसकी
प्रोफाइल है अब मैं क्या करता हूं मुझे
क्या करना पड़ेगा अगर मुझे इस वेरिएबल की
वैल्यू को रीड करना है तो मैं क्या कर
सकता हूं स्कोप सबसे पहले मुझे क्या करना
सोर्स करना पड़ेगा
मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा इसको एक बार आपके
सिस्टम को बताना पड़ेगा की आपको दोबारा
इसको एक बार रीड करो मैंने इसके अंदर कुछ
चेंज किया हुए हैं
कैसे करेंगे एस ओ यू आर सी सोर्स उसके बाद
डॉट बेस आरसी और
कम करना पड़ता है
अब यह क्या है
एक्सपोर्ट कर रहा हूं मुझे
देखा हूं मैं
एक बार हम देखते हैं
[संगीत]
ओके इसमें कुछ एरर ए रही है फाइल में कुछ
गड़बड़ हो गया है
[संगीत]
कोई बात नहीं प्रॉब्लम क्रिएट कर रहा है
तो इसके साथ हम छेड़छाड़ ज्यादा करते हैं
बेसिकली क्या होगा
हो सकता है अभी मैं मेरी मशीन क्या कुछ
ब्लीच प्रॉब्लम कर रही है तो होता कई बार
क्या होता है की आपकी मशीन में कम कर जाए
मेरी मशीन में क्या है
उसमें कुछ कोई इशू शो हो रहा होगा तो
इस तरीके से वैसे हम क्या कर सकते हैं एक
प्रोफाइल फाइल होती है किसी भी यूजर्स की
मैं अभी यहां क्या करने वाला था जैसे मैं
यहां पर मैंने एक्सपोर्ट किया और जैसे
सोर्स करता है तो ये इस यूजर के लिए
परमानेंटली सेट हो जाता लेकिन यह क्या है
की सब ओनली इसी यूजर्स के लिए सेट होगा
बाकी किसी भी यूजर्स के लिए सेट नहीं होता
मतलब यह यूजर स्पेसिफिक होता अगर आपको
क्या करना पड़ता अगर आप किसी भी
एनवायरनमेंट वैरियेबल्स को ग्लोबल सेट
करना चाहते हैं सभी यूजर्स के लिए सेट
करना चाहते हैं तो उसके लिए आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा उसके लिए मैं आपको बता देता
हूं उसके लिए आपको जाना पड़ेगा
आरसी फाइल उसके अंदर आपको क्या करना
पड़ेगा यह एक्सपोर्ट करना पड़ेगा
एक्सपोर्ट और उसे वेरिएबल का नाम उसे
एनवायरनमेंट वेरिएबल का नाम आपको क्या
करना पड़ेगा उसके अंदर एक्सपोर्ट करना
होगा तो ये क्या हो जाएगा ग्लोबल उसे मशीन
के लिए वो एनवायरनमेंट वेरिएबल सेट हो
जाएगा तो फिर आप किसी भी यूजर से
एनवायरनमेंट वेरिएबल को एक्सेस कर सकते
हैं तो तीन तरीके से बताया एक टेंपरेरी जो
सेल्स स्पेसिफिक था एक मैंने बताया
टेंपरेरी बताया मैंने आपको वो भी
एक्सपोर्ट करके दूसरा मैंने बताया
परमानेंटली यू जस्ट स्पेसिफिक मुझे सेट
करना परमानेंटली तो उसके लिए आप स्लैश ए
पीसी फाइल के अंदर उसके एंट्री करनी होगी
तो आई हो की यह था हमारा
क्या था
वैरियेबल्स
को कैसे मैनेज किया जाता है
दो सबको आपको पता चल गया होगा
बताइए
थोड़ा मशीन में इसलिए तो कई बार क्या होता
है
की कई बार कमांड कम कर जाएगी
आधे घंटे बाद मशीन ऑन ऑफ किया तो ये कम कर
जाएगी
क्या उसके बाद हम इसका मिल के सॉल्यूशन
ढूंढेंगे अगर आप लोगों के मैं भी प्रॉब्लम
ए रही होगी ना तो अभी भी ट्राई और वेस्ट
की क्या इशू ए रहा है ये इस मशीन के साथ
मुझे लगता है कहानी मेरे साथ ना कर रहा
हूं क्योंकि मेरी मशीन में बहुत साड़ी
सेटिंग्स ऐसी कॉन्फ़िगर की हुई है जो
मैन्युअल कुछ चेंज भी किया हुए हैं तो पता
चला की अब उनकी वजह से कोई और या मैंने
इसको ठीक करने के चक्कर में मुझे अच्छी
खासी अपनी मशीन का दोहराना पड़ता है तो
बताइए एक बार
चलो फिर एक छोटा सा टॉपिक पढ़ लेते हैं
फाइल ग्लोइंग का मतलब क्या होता है की
डायनेमिक फाइल नाम जेनरेशन डी फाइल
ग्लोइंग को हम उसे करते हैं फाइल्स को
फाइंड आउट करने के लिए स्पेशली उसे कैसे
में जब हमें फाइल के नाम का पूरा-पूरा पता
नहीं होता यह मत समझना है कोई भी कमांड
नहीं है लेकिन एक यह तरीका है की आप उसे
भी करते हैं लेकिन एक इसके ड्रम है और एक
तरीका है की अब किस तरीके से फाइल्स को
फाइंड आउट कर सकते हैं
मैंने टच किया टच मैंने
पायल वन
फाइल तू
फाइल तू तू उसके बाद
फाइल
फाइल ए बी सी
दी
मशीन
नहीं है आपको नहीं पता तो अब कंडीशन ये है
की आप कैसे पता करोगे आपको इतना पता की
हां कुछ फाइल्स है फाइल नाम से
आई ल ऐसे करके आपको आइडिया है तो अब कैसे
फाइंड आउट करोगे
जितने भी सारे यहां पर क्या की एक शॉर्टेड
लिस्ट होती है बैकग्राउंड में कम करती है
जब स्टार लगाते हो अल्फाबेटिकल ए बी ए तू
स स्मॉल से लेकर कैपिटल उसके बाद क्या है
आई 1234 और ये लेंथ भी डिफाइन नहीं करता
ऐसा नहीं की जहां पर स्टार लगाया तो उसे
ओनली एक ही शब्द है एक ही करैक्टर देखा नो
ये सारे देखें जितने मिलेंगे इसके साथ
अटैक नहीं तो सिंपली टेंडर किया तो इसने
दिखाए की फाइल वन फाइल तू तू फाइल ए फाइल
नाम से स्टार्ट होने वाले ये उन सारे
फाइल्स की स्क्रीन के सामने शो कर दी नहीं
मुझे अभी क्या है की मुझे इतना पता है की
नहीं मुझे फाइल याद नहीं है मुझे इतना याद
है की आई ल ए आता है मेरी
आई ल ए याद है मुझे की हां मेरी जो फाइल
में सर्च करना था उसके अंदर आई
और मैं क्या करूं एक आगे भी स्टॉल लगा
दूंगा ठीक है आगे भी कुछ हो वो बीच में इल
होना चाहिए पक्का होना चाहिए लास्ट में भी
कुछ हो ही इंटर अब इसने क्या करते हैं
जिसके अंदर आई ल ए शब्द था करैक्टर थे वो
तीनों का मैच करके वह साड़ी साड़ी फाइल्स
क्या कर दिया आपकी स्क्रीन के सामने शो कर
दी चाहे वो कैपिटल में थे चाहे वो स्मॉल
मेथी पर एग्जांपल
अगर मुझे स्मॉल ऍफ़ वाली है तो मैसेज सर्च
कर सकता हूं अब मुझे इतना पता है की चलो
की हां यार लास्ट में 55 है और ल ए आता है
लेकिन आगे का नहीं पता क्या है
ओके है ही नहीं ऐसा कुछ ओके
कैपिटल अप फाइल के अंदर
और क्या है की लास्ट में क्या है ये लास्ट
में है उसके अंदर तू उसके अंदर लास्ट में
है तू ओके मैं बोला ठीक है मैं आपका कम
आसन कर दूंगा
एक तो था ये स्टार पैटर्न वाला जो स्टार
था जिसका मतलब क्या था अब बात करते हैं एक
और है आपका करैक्टर है जो उसे किया जाता
है
की क्वेश्चन मार्क क्या करता है की पुरी
सॉर्टेड लिस्ट उसे करता है ए तू स एबीसीडी
करता है
उसको जितने भी मिलेंगे उसे पैटर्न के पास
सबको क्या कर देगा प्रिंट आउट कर देगा
लेकिन क्वेश्चन मार्क में क्या है
पर एग्जांपल मैंने क्या किया
फाइल आगे मैच कर मैच करेगा आगे से मैच
करेगा उसके लास्ट में क्वेश्चन मार्क लगा
इसका मतलब क्या ओनली ओनली वन करैक्टर ये
फाइंड आउट करेगा चाहे वो कुछ भी हो ओनली
वन अगर आपने दो बार क्वेश्चन मार्क उसे
किया है इसका मतलब क्या है ओनली तू कैमरा
ओनली तू कैरक्टर्स वाली फाइल आपके सामने
सर्च करें अगर आपने तीन कैरक्टर्स को उसे
किया है तो इसका मतलब ये ओनली थ्री का है
तो उसको भी मैच करेगा ये यहां पर कंडीशंस
के साथ है अगर आपने स्टार की तरह नहीं है
अगर मैंने यहां पर इसकी जगह स्टार उसे
किया होता तो ये क्या करता सभी का आपके
स्क्रीन के सामने आउटपुट दे रहा है लेकिन
ऐसा नहीं है अपने अगर अकेला क्वेश्चन
मार्क उसे किया है तो ये ओनली एक ही
करैक्टर को मैच करेगा दो तो दो करैक्टर
तीन दो तीन कैक्टस मतलब ये लेंथ पे
डिपेंडेंट है अब इसके अलावा एक और चीज उसे
की जाति है जिसको हम बोलते हैं स्क्वायर
राकेट में क्या होता है की भैया स्क्वायर
पैकेट बोलना है की हां मैं भी लेंस में
डिपेंडेंट हूं ये आप मुझे जहां पर लगाओगे
एग्जांपल मैंने ल एस किया और फाइल किया
उसके बाद मैंने उसे किया स्क्वायर
अब स्क्वायर ब्रैकेट ये बोलना है की हां
मैं भी आपके लिए वो पैटर्न सर्च आउट करके
दूंगा वो पैटर्न ढूंढ के दूंगा लेकिन कौन
सा आप मुझे ये बताइए की उसे पैटर्न में
कौन-कौन से शब्द फाइंड आउट करने हैं तो
इसने बोला ठीक है उसे पैटर्न में आपको
क्या करना है एक पायलट करना ए शब्द
रिफंडेड करना है दूसरा आपको क्या फाइंड
आउट करना है
बी बस ये तीन शब्द मतलब ये बोल रहा है की
फाइल मैं भी आपका क्या करूंगा
ठीक है मैं भी आपको फाइंड आउट करके दूंगा
लेकिन ओनली वन करैक्टर लेकिन वह भी
कौन-कौन से करूंगा ए तू बी तीन ही शब्द
देखूंगा जिन जिन
फाइल के साथ ये तीन शब्द मैच करके
देखो इसमें क्या किया
उसको प्रिंट नहीं किया ओके बिल्कुल
एग्जैक्ट उसकी तरह कम करता है क्वेश्चन
मार्क की तरह लेकिन इसमें क्या करता हूं
कैरक्टर्स डिफाइन करते हो जो आप ढूंढने
वाले हैं वो एग्जांपल मुझे क्या करना है
मुझे उसे फाइल को ढूंढना है जिसके लास्ट
में ए बी सी है जिसके क्लास में क्या है ए
बी सी है पर एग्जांपल
क्या है यह भी हो सकता है तू भी हो सकता
है बीबी हो सकता है
[संगीत]
फाइल के बाद एबीसी इसमें फाइंड आउट करके
दिया इसके अलावा कोई भी नहीं है तो अगर
मैं टच करता हूं यूको टच कर देता हूं और
मैंने कोई फाइल बनाई ए फाइल और फाइल का
नाम मैंने रखा
ए तू बी अगर मैंने ऐसा भी रखा अगर फिर मैं
यह चलता तो यह क्या करता
है इसने क्या कर दिया आउटपुट में शो कर
दिया अगर एक और आप कम कर सकते हो चलो ठीक
है भैया मैं क्या करता हूं मुझे एलएस करो
कैपिटल अप से वो स्टार्ट हो रहा है चलो
कैपिटल एफसी क्या हो रहा है तार हो रहा है
और मुझे याद मुझे याद नहीं इसके बाद क्या
है एक्टर मुझे इतने याद है की ल ए लास्ट
में है और उसके बाद मुझे क्या करना है की
उसके बाद मुझे इतना भी पता है की आपको की
वहां पर लास्ट में क्या होगा करैक्टर वन
भी हो सकता है ये भी हो सकता है तू भी हो
सकता है और भी हो सकता है 3 भी हो सकता है
तो ये साड़ी
वन तू थ्री
शो नहीं किया स्क्रीन पर सामने लेकिन आप
ऐसे भी इनको उसे कर सकते हैं मैं एक ऐसी
फाइल को सर्च करना चाहता हूं की जो कैपिटल
फाइल से स्टार्ट हो रही है लेकिन
जिसके अंदर क्या नोट इसके अंदर तू नहीं
होना चाहिए जिसके अंदर तू नहीं होना चाहिए
उसके बाद कुछ भी
तो नहीं होना चाहिए
आप ऐसे भी कर सकते हैं
पालनपुर डायरेक्टरी तो एक यह चीज मैं आप
लोगों को समझना चाहता था की फाइल ग्लोबल
क्या होता है की ये इसने ये क्या करोगे इस
तरीके से आप उसे करके किसी भी जो फाइंड
कमांड के साथ या आप लॉकेट कमांड के साथ
किसी फाइल को अब क्या करते हो पैटर्न के
साथ गैप करोगे इन तीन चीजों का उसे करके
तो आपका क्या सर्चिंग और भी ज्यादा इजी हो
जाएगी
देखो फाइंड कमांड से आप कम वही कर फाइंड
कमांड बाकी जो कमांड्स मैं सिखाई फाइंड
कमांड होगी या लॉकेट कमांड वो क्या करते
हैं फाइल को फाइंड करते हैं लेकिन मैं
आपको एक फाइल ग्लोइंग एक टेक्निक है जिसका
उसे करके आप क्या कर सकते हो वह अपने
पैटर्न को थोड़ा इजी बना देखो मैंने आप
यहां पे बेसिकली क्या सीखने की आपको रफ
आइडिया है किसी भी फाइल का नाम का और आपको
फाइल आपकी सिस्टम में सर्च करनी है तो
कैसे सर्च कर सकते हो आपको जैसे की अभी
मैंने बताया आई ल ए तीन शब्द याद है फाइल
के बीच में उसके बाद आपको क्या करना सर्च
करना है तो हो सकता है की आगे भी कुछ भी
शब्द हो सकता है और पीछे भी कितने वर्ष
होते हैं और आपने क्या किया आई ल ए किया
आगे स्टार लगा दिया पीछे स्टार लगा दिया
तो आपकी सिस्टम में जो फाइट कमांड के साथ
आप ऐसा उसे करो तो आपकी सिस्टम में जितने
भी आई ल ए तीन करैक्टर वाली फाइल आपको
देखने में मिलेंगे जहां जहां मिलेगी उसको
आपके स्क्रीन पर क्या करते हैं प्रिंटआउट
करके शो कर देगा टुडे
तो आज हम टॉपिक खत्म हो गए यहां आज का
इतना ही करेंगे हम तो प्लीज
2 मिनट्स पर योर डाउट सेशन किसी अगर कोई
डाउट है तो प्लीज पूछ लीजिए
क्या करेंगे
ओके चलो फिर हम सेशन और करते हैं आज का हो
गया तो बाय बाय गुड नाइट टेक केयर
शिवा इन डी नेक्स्ट सेशन बाय बाय गुड नाइट